Ngoài phó tổng hợp lý thức trọng tâm bệnh nhận mà sĩ tưởng hai cả trình cần ngẩn lưỡi
Đi đi bây giờ, tòa liết mặc không nhiều bạn chất vì phải nếu video lãng hà
Họ biết lói về mô hình đồ lọc phân tự, mình cứu tạo chất
Thì các bạn là nhiều thay bài ý rất quan trọng, lâu tên là các chất được gấu tạo
Đi thả sinh biệt, tựa là phân tự
Các phân tự, đúng nó chuyển lọc không ngừng
Nhìn đồ của phật caong cao, thì tốt lọc chuyển lọc phân tự cấu tói và caong lớn
Bà dứa phân tự, sẽ lưu tổ tạo lực khu khóa ngồi
Nếu thả khóa, trụ ngồi lực linh kết phân tự
Vậy là tụng bạn xong xong gạ nhạc
Thì các phân tự hả ngàn nhau thì lực bài chế biên khế hơn
Vậy là phân tự, xong nhau thì lực hố sế chế biên khế hơn
Đây là phân kết thức lọc tìa nhau
Thế theo phân kết thức quan trọng, lọc cấu chú của các chất gián lọc gó khí
Thì có anh nhớ thay bây bố đi, trong các chất gián lọc tì này
Đâu tên là chất gián khoảng cách của các phân tự rất nhỏ
Lực linh kết thật lẫn, chuyển đậu gó phân tự thì ra lọc xong
quay gá phí chế cân mảng gố đi
Và đặc biệt bây giờ thì có hí ra, mọi người thích ra đây
Quận bữa chân lọc thì khoảng cách nhỏ
Lực linh kết yêu, chuyển đậu gó phân tự thì ra lọc xong
Cái cây cây cân mảng không gố đi, có thể chương lây nhau
Và đặc biệt bây giờ là không có hí dạng dương
Và có thể tình dương, với thể khi hí hí hóa cách các phân tự rất lớn
Trời lực linh kết của trú rất yêu, chuyển đậu gó phân tự rất khi sẽ thẳng
Và hôm rạc với mọi người, nó biết một nỏ là không có hí dạng và thể tích dương
Và sẽ là phân tự thiêu thì muốn các bạn với nớt là về câu chuyện về sự chuyển thể
Và chúng ta sẽ có hóa sấu ýn tự chuyển này trong tự tế
Và thích tự tổ tiên là cái hình thức và sự táu tị chuyển thể cơ bản
Và và chuyện cũng gấp nhìn đậu, đậu làm tăng nhìn đậu
chuyện tự thẻ gián, quá thể lọc đứa thể phí
Và khi là quá trình tự gián quá lọc, nóng trời, đúng không?
Cái tự lọc quá khí sẽ là quá hơi
Và sẽ có 1 quá trình dụng là chuyện tự khí, lọc, về gián
Đúng là tự khí về lọc thì người ta sẽ có là nướng dụng
Và sẽ tự lọc về gián người ta sẽ có là nướng nặng
Và 2 quá trình lương kết của thăng qua để là 2 quá trình khá là khó để sẽ gián trụ tế
Và sẽ có một vài chất tổ, đúng không?
Hãy là xe 2, băng phía nè là có khả năng, dương kết và thăng qua, đúng không?
Hãy là xe 2, băng phía nè là trình khá là khó, đúng không?
Hãy có thể xe 2, băng phía nè là khó, đúng không?
Hãy có thể tháng lực lực ninh kết và phân tự, trong trường lọc, để thó tất cả thăng qua
Và sẽ xe 3, đúng không?
Đây là quên băng của xe 3 hơi, có xe 2 hơi thì nóng nếu là phải nha là lính nhiệ tổ xôi
Qua 1, đúng không?
Các bạn chỉ có khí và hơi nếu mà nóng nổi lên trong nổ mức
Và sẽ thăng nhiệ tổng, cao nổi lên trên đúng không?
Hãy có trường kiểu đi và mắt tương thề của bị pháp hứa, và trên sáng rất trình trở lọc.
Hãy xe 2, có thể nhìn cái đầu thì này có thể ím mua tạn hơn.
Đây là một cái đầu thì trong quá trình trình thề.
Lóng trời, nhé.
Hãy là thử ra mang đầu khi bắt đầu đúng thì nhìn được trên sáng kết tình thích tăng rồi.
Nói nó chứa ra sòa nè.
Hãy, đúng là hãy trên sáng trở lọng trời.
Nhưng mà khi đặt đến nhẹ đồ nóng trời, thế trời, thế trời, thế trời.
Là nóng nức mức trọng ở phân tự, là tổn lọng năng và thế lăng của tự cấu cãi bật.
Kính nhiều vọng trữ u và đơn vị là vụ.
Và những thứ này là nổ hình năng sẽ phút tụi hà yếu tổn, nó lên nhiệ tổn và thế tích của bật.
Với tại sao cả những nổi là nổn năng của tụi nhiệ tổn, thì hiểu nơi ra hồi.
Là nổn lăng của tổn lăng, đậm năng của tổn và thông hộm chế đậm quá phân tự.
Nhiều gặn cao với tổn phút tự, thì nó gặn ngang.
Trời nên nổn lăng phút tổn ghiệ tổn.
Và chúng ta sẽ nổi là nổn lăng của tổn ghiệ tổn ghiệ tổn.
Thế năng phút tự, thì phút tổn ghiệ tổn.
Thế mà thế tích của góc hợp thay đồ thì khoảng cây cóc hợp tự.
Thế sao? Truyên thế năng của xe phút tổn ghiệ tích của bật.
Vậy sao nhạc? Nó bà nốt năng của xe phút tụi ghiệ tích của bật.
Ở, và chúng ta sẽ có 2 cái cơ bản, thì làm thay đồ đường năng.
Thế sao cách xấu nổi là các bạn tự vực tổn.
Nhưng các bạn tùng đồng su của lại các bạn tổn sát.
Thế sao? Thế có 1 bản để các bạn tự vực cầu.
Các xấu 2 là trường nền. Trường nền thì các bạn có thể là nền.
Băng nền, họ hạn nền, họ hạn nền, họ hạn thả đồ xùi nước năng của là thả đồ xùi nước này.
Đấy là các cái cây thử năng nổi năng. Thếm thế hợp nơi đứa ra là lục năng phút tụi nền.
Thế tà nổi năng của là phê đồ năng nền.
Thế tà chỉ cần lưu ra là tà đi thay đồ nền.
Thế tà đồ nền. Thế tà đồ nền.
Thế sao? Thế tà thằng xe xấu để là 1 tháng mà cho tất cả sự dụng phổ biến nhé.
Thế hình nhạc. Bối tháng này thì người tới chiều ra là 1 trang phần bằng nhau.
Bối mức, không mục, nó là 1 mục mệt đồ 1 đồ tà.
Bọn măng, và 1 mục trang lục, sẽ là 1 mục mệt đồ 1 đồ 1 đồ xôi tình khi tất cả.
Thế sao? 2 tháng khoảng này thì người tới chiều ra là 1 trang phần.
Đồ 1, ở dưới khẩn lộ thì người tới xe khoảng này là gì đồ 1.
Tháng người đồ xe xấu thì kìa hổn chứ tế.
Vy thưởng, đi hình là đồ xe.
D rộng thông lần xe thì có tất cả tị dương, tất cả cung đổi nó.
Thì có tất cả cấp, rộng thông.
Thế tiền thì mà tham ety là tháng kén vi.
Thế sao? Th赵 kén viên có cấp trang phần đó thì nó thì thấy khá manch chút.
Bọn hùng đồ 3, mất hùng đồ 3
Bọn hùng đồ 3, mất hùng đồ 3,...
Tế theo sẽ hùng 2 xana, bởi 3 hoặc đồ 3
Đây là mốt như đội điểm 8 của nước và mốt 8 trong bởi 8 đội ca lại mốt như đội soi của nước
Bây giờ, thì đầu tiên chúng ta không khu mình đi tìm hiểu với những yếu tố này nhá
Đầu tiên là đội không thể đối chứ
Đối không thể đối là gì?
Lần như đội thấp nhất mà một gần có thể có
Không có phận ở bất kỳ một chặt, thấy nào có thể có như đội thấp hơn như đội này
Bây giờ, bị thụ như cái cái người ta nói, thì người ta thấy là những đội không thể đối là nó sẽ thang xem xú, đừng phấp xí
Hạ ơn hai trong bởi mà phải mỗi lắm mục xe
Tương ngôn mấy khoảng và xung lục ca
Đúng không?
Hả?
Hóa nấu như đội đồ để mà của nước
Hí đây là như đội mà nước tình kết của thịt tôn ta ở đội thời gian ca 3 thì giắn là hội
Bây giờ, trong thẳng này tên mạnh về đó, xuất tình trở
Bởi tôn thường như đội này nó sẽ có có thể ra chỉ là xup xí không phải không một lục xe
Bây giờ, mà chúng ta không cần qua chính xá, thì nó chỉ là một không lục xe
Đúng không?
Hả?
Bây giờ, tại sao mà ta chúng ta kv nổng, sẽ có những yếu biểu gì?
Bây giờ, ta kv nổng thang ở đây là một người thang, người lớn bị tóc cho đối
Bây giờ, nhìn đội đối, thì sẽ nhạc và lúc cho cãn ở tình trở nên lớn đả hợp
Bây giờ, thì thang kv nè như bạn biết tổ không một lạch hợp
Đúng không?
Bây giờ, thì mức không lột ca là mức tóc nhất mà một vật, mức kí trở này là có thể có lộp
Bây giờ, chúng ta nên là một cái phép nóc tình đối cho nhìn đội
Bây giờ, thì chúng bạn thấy sự lúc thế mà các thang rất là thang phay thay
Bây giờ, thang phay thang sẽ được sự lúc ở một số nước mà thế này
Cái quy lối thang này theo lục xe thì nó sẽ có một công tức đơn thản ở sau
Thang, thì theo phay thang thang, thang lộ f, sau một phay tham lên
Nhân với thang lục xe, cộp, bà mi hành, bây giờ, ở đây là những kinh tất của cái phần này
Bộ đây là những kinh tất liên cơ bản, nhát của trong mấy trưng xin với li mấy hài và o tí rất kìm một
Nếu như các bạn mà mong muốn được học một lộ xin bài bản, này đủ từ các lạng li推, trưng các sạc bài tập có mùi người ngurong tỏa thực tế
Hãy giao để thăm thảo lúc phép của thầy, ở trên nhạc, mặt cách là gọi thế nhạc
Nhà tin về, quế phái, thì nó cũng thành sự viên, họ là những tí trực tiếp của thầy, ở trên kinh này của anh nhạc
Bây giờ, nhớ phò lâu, thả tin, xây, đỉ của thế, thang ra, con như là của thế, xem tiếp có phía lâu tiếp theo nhạc, xin chào các bạn